hallo und herzlich willkommen hier aus
der maria theresien kaserne heute am
donnerstag macht man ein
ausdauertraining mit euch dafür mal
wieder einen spezialgast dabei wir haben
den zugführer war aber mit der lupe und
der batman spieler der profi
badmintonspieler und wir könnten uns
dann besser helfen auf kleinem raum auf
engen rahmen hochintensiv die ausdauer
zu trainieren
die niki ist wieder mit der beta leid
euch durch das programm und am besten
ist luca du stellst du ganz gut selbst
vor ja hallo mein name ist luca frau
aber ich bin seit über zehn jahren
beiden profi 2012 auch beim harry
sportzentrum und momentan befinde ich
mich mitten in der olympia-quali bzw
sie beginnt im märz wieder weiterzugehen
weil sie war ja durch die pandemie
unterbrochen
danke du hast mal gesagt du bist du
gesagt mehrfacher staatsmeister in der
olympia-qualifikation aber kleines
hindernis ist nur mitarbeiter aus der
shooter operation kommt wie steht's mit
der genesung mit der heilung
es schaut sehr gut aus also ich bin vor
sechs monaten operiert worden
bereits voll im soll und es schaut gut
aus dass ich eben zum beginn bzw wenn es
wieder weitergeht mit der qualle mit der
mertz anfang märz wieder voll gesagt
okay und vor allem haben wir heute das
große problem weil man ja gesagt haben
wir trainieren die ausdauer wir werden
uns viel bewegen das heißt
wadenmuskulatur aufwärts bis zum gesäß
wird richtig richtig belastet werden hat
und ich glaube das ist einer der punkte
der beim badminton spielen sehr wichtig
ist oder muskulär die beine müssen wir
dafür arbeiten genauso beinarbeit ist
eigentlich das um und auf im badminton
wir haben viele aus fortschritt viele
sprünge ganz rauf ganz runter und
schnell vor zurück auf einen fehler des
ansonsten recht umfassend war das eine
hohe belastung spricht aus eigener
erfahrung etwas leidgeprüft wenn man als
hobbysportler badminton spielt und so
wie es mir gar ministerin am freitag
nicht bewegen kann
woran kann das liegen das ist
wahrscheinlich selbst recht sportlich
bist und dann in ausfallschritte gehst
aber am ende des tages ist es doch nicht
gewohnt also der kopf so was geht dann
muss ich nicht aber trotzdem danke für
die blumen
ok dann legen wir los nicht du bist
bereit bei dir passt alles
dann wird immer einlaufen lockeres
laufen an stand das herz kreislauf
system bringen wir ein bisschen schwung
dann werden ein bisschen mobilisieren
wir haben ein aus dem yoga abgeleitetes
kurzes warm up programm noch mit dem
joker machen und anschließend 30
sekunden belasten in der ausdauer mit
sprüngen mit der teppich immer dann noch
da reinkommt und 30 sekunden pause
machen und das ganze zwei durchgänge und
die halbe stunde ist dann auch schon
wieder erledigt ok haben wir vorwärts
kreisen ganz klar weiter laufen dabei
genau und arme rückwärts kreisen dagegen
gleich probieren und die richtung
wechseln
kurz aus lockern oberkörper verdrehen
linke rechte seite genauer kenner
schwungmasse mitnehmen
manchmal das ganze klaus der vorbeuge
das heißt gleich deutschland gehört ein
vorbeuge und zu den beinen hin unter
greifen
kurz aus lockern aufrichten locker
weiter laufen am stand luca tourist
vorher gesagt du bist seit zwölf jahren
leistungssportler wie lange plant noch
ist eine gute frage
ein bayer hoffe ich geht es noch aber
ich werde es dann nach den olympischen
spielen und reflektieren und schauen wo
wir auf jeden fall weiter okay wie werde
ich dann sehen wir ja wie gesagt mit dem
gerade ist ein sport der extrem explosiv
ist der extrem schnell ist und da spürt
man natürlich dann an den übrigen
körperlichen verfall aber jedes jahr wo
man älter wird wird man natürlich dann
nicht unbedingt spritziger und schneller
aber so darf zurück weiterbewegt ja vor
allem die regenerationszeiten werden
länger das heißt ja man muss einfach ein
bisschen mehr sein körper schauen aber
das darf normalerweise noch immer ganz
genau und autoritären wo man mit
erfahrung nichts mehr gutmachen gerade
spricht aus eigener erfahrung her
aber du bist so weit bist du bereit so
weit bin ich zum guten tag herr diehl
auslagern
hände auf sie gelenkt kreisen im
kniegelenk schau mal das mantra der
mobilität und der bislang gelenkschmiere
hersteller im kniegelenk richtung
wechseln
kurz schütteln die beine um rechtes bein
anheben und kreisen im unterschenkel
gleich das gleichgewicht ein bisschen
mitnehmen richtung wechseln und die
seite wechseln
bist du über feder beispielen
hinausgekommen aus dem bett mit dem
spiel die richtung wechseln und doktor
ist ist dieser sport ausgleich geld wo
der gott sagen also das kann man
jederzeit wenn man in die halle darf
aber natürlich ausprobieren wir wechseln
wieder die seite das heißt rechtes bein
hoch geben sprunggelenk reisen und die
richtung wechseln seite wechseln zweite
stein richtung wechseln und kurz
auslagern
ok teilnehmer mit obwohl man heute viel
mit dem ball machen aber wir haben schon
kehrt den ganzen körper jedes gelenk
einmal mobilisieren am tag das ist eine
gute variante um entsprechend auch viel
zu bleiben beweglich zu bleiben deswegen
wenn man das jetzt mit auf kopf auf die
linke seite schauen rechte seite schaden
im wechsel und nach oben und nach unten
schauen und luca neben der qualifikation
für olympia
was dann so deine sportlichen highlights
besonders stolz in deiner karriere
der neunte platz für den european clowns
nach links und rechts gibt
beziehungsweise 1 17 der platz bei der
em war staatsmeistertitel
mannschaftsmeistertitel in der ersten
deutschen bundesliga
und ja ich war nummer 52 der welt das
war bis jetzt meine höchste platzierung
ist das vergleichbar mit dem tennis
weltrangliste beim badminton ja als
absolut zur gleichschaltung kopf rollen
von der linken seite hinüber die brust
auf die rechte und richtung wechseln
genau wie kurz auslagern kurze
ausschnitte und das bewegen
jetzt müssen wir schauen dass man das
herz kreislauf system tatsächlich noch
richtig ankurbeln weil die belastung die
man noch machen wird intensiv und das
braucht man immer auf wenn man natürlich
auch das heißt jetzt stand live mit
start-stopp erkennst das prinzip wenn
ich sage start läuft sie jetzt zwar
schneller
und wenn ich sage stopp läuft normal
weiter jetzt schloss und stadt
rohstoff statt
stock einmal machen wir das ganze stadt
ist okay kurz es locker ich würde
vorschlagen beginnen denn yoga wo am
block mit hinein bin ich sehr gespannt
darf gebieten einmal den ersten
bewegungs abschnitt einmal vorzuzeigen
wir geben die arme nach oben drehen die
damen nach hinten aktivieren denn laut
aktivieren noch das gesäß haben eine
gute spannung das ist die
ausgangsposition
und dann dann schieben wir das gesäß
nach hinten bauen eine wirklich schöne
spannung in der wirbelsäule aufgehen so
weit runter wie es geht bis in den
oberschenkel hinten zieht dann mal los
gehen runter okay ganz kurzen stopp in
der position die kita gebieten dass die
90 grad verdreht und noch einmal aus der
gestreckten position von oben runter
geht das mandat die bewegungs
knotenpunkte name heraus fassen können
gerade rücken geht nach unten so lange
spannung haltbar ist und im oberschenkel
nicht zu viel zug ist und jetzt die
spannung raus nehmen und mit den händen
genau hinunter ok nächster schritt
so steigt man mit einem großen schritt
mit dem linken bein nach hinten
das linke bein das hintere setzt
gestreckt und wir versuchen uns so weit
wie möglich aufzudrehen und schauen der
handfläche nach wieder prima da nach
außen haben eine gute spannung links und
rechts und wirklich mobilisieren die
wirbelsäule gut okay das heißt aus der
position gestreckte beine oberkörper
nach unten hängend einen weiten
ausfallschritt linkes bein zurück und
mit der rechten hand auf den kopf sieht
nach ok und dann geht's weiter
genau dann wollen wir den abend wieder
zurück also in dem fall gemacht das
zweite bein dann nach china steigen
zurück schieben das gesäß richtung decke
versuchen eine richtig gute spannung
wird auf die oberschenkelrückseite zu
bekommen
und wenn es dann wirklich schön zieht
dann lösen wir das ganze und dann gibt
es zwei varianten die einfachere ist wir
gehen so direkt nach vor
genau drei makler der das heißt direkt
nach vor einmal den oberkörper durch
biegen nach oben durchsehen zu geringer
spannung vorne auch in die
bauchmuskulatur hüftbeuger hinein in
einer video gesäß anspannen
dann bleiben wir kurz drinnen dann gehen
wir wieder zurück okay wir stets wieder
nach oben fußsohlen so gut wie es geht
am boden
ganz genau und jetzt wieder mit einem
großen schritt dieses mal mit dem
anderen bein rechnung seite nach vor
beziehungsweise ja diese angefangen
genau angefangen hat mit jesus die linke
seite ja genau hinteres bein gestreckt
jetzt die andere seite aufdrehen so weit
wie möglich
manchmal knackten in der wirbelsäule ich
hab mal die gleichen zeiten nicht geben
wenn es passiert ist zu hause kein
problem wechselt schnell die position
oberkörper aufdrehen
kurz die spannung halten wieder runter
gehen genau dann steigen wir noch vor
und das was man vorher nach unten
gemacht haben machen wir jetzt nach oben
das ist arme in die vorhalte und dann
aufrichten gestreckte position ganz
draufgänger und einen durchgenommen wird
vorstellen wir machen unser zweites
meinung zu verfestigen und dann gehen
wir in unser werk hat eine und
staatenlos arme oberkörper gestreckt
daumen schauen nach hinten jetzt in die
vorhalte gehen das heißt oberkörper
runter bis der zug im oberschenkel wade
ist es gut spürbar ist kurz warten
spannung raus mit den händen richtung 10
gehen nächste schritt war zurücksteigen
langer schritt zurück und das bein
gestreckt und hochdrehen hat dem arm
aschau an der hand nachschauen kurz
warten wieder zurückdrehen zweites bein
zurück steigen
becken nach hinten gruppe nach oben
einmal nach vorne durch beugen durch
bieten jetzt war gerade wieder zurück
nach oben oder ganz genau
ja also wieder zurückgehen und jetzt mit
der anderen seite vor wenn ich das
richtig im kopf hab richtig gerne andere
seite steigt vor nick ist das jetzt
merkt man spürt sie gleich wo man schon
war und wieder hochdrehen interesse knie
gestreckt ja genau versucht da reingehen
die streckung super wieder raus wieder
dazu steigen
und jetzt umgekehrt wieder aufrichten in
die gespannte position arme nach vorne
und ganz aufrichten genau einmal durch
lockern und jetzt sollte man super cool
bereit sein für das werk hat das machen
wir zehn übungen die alle mit bewegung
zu tun haben waren die jeweils 30
sekunden mit 30 sekunden pause wo man
das ganze erklären erste übung
nähmaschine
keine sorge ja wir fahren es nicht an
handwerklich zu betätigen sondern nur
der begriff glaube ich für ganz
schnelles laufen am standort ganz genau
mag eine möglichst wenig abheben da die
trotzdem bieten zeigt uns einmal kurz
vor das heißt eine wenig abheben kurze
tapings ganz kurze bodenkontakt
zeitgenau und das ganze immer auch mal
30 sekunden und in fünf sekunden
startbereit machen
21 und zeit läuft 30 sekunden
und da ist jetzt ganz wichtig dass hier
die 30 sekunden schafft die gleiche
frequenz die anfangs arbeiter zu machen
und nicht langsamer zu werden und zehn
sekunden brauchen wir schon haben wir
erst je nachdem von welcher seite das
man sieht 30 sekunden wären dann nämlich
ganz schön lang
[Applaus]
zehn sekunden auf 321 ersten 30 schon
anstrengend ja diese bewegung so lange
so schnell zu machen
okay die zweite übung ausfallschritt
sprünge die übung kennt sie
wir haben die asche die variante gehabt
mit nach vor steigen zurücksteigen ihr
sucht sich jetzt die ausfallschritt
variante die für euch passt wir haben
auch in die dynamische variante das
heißt hineinspringen in die position auf
die beinachse achten seitenwechsel
sprung und so weiter und sofort möglich
sagt kontrolliert die beinachse
oberkörper stabil gerade aufrecht zeit
läuft auch hier versucht den oberkörper
aufrecht zu lassen
das heißt nicht in einen rundrücken zu
kommen sondern bleibt wirklich stolz und
aufrecht und groß halbzeit ist erreicht
15 sekunden nur noch 5 3 2 1 1 durch
ausfallschritt sprünge intensive
belastung intensiv übung man für diese
sofort wieder warm up programm denke mal
für deine deine trainingseinheiten für
mich ist das anstrengend
ich habe aber eine übung auch gewohnte
bewegung und dadurch natürlich dann
weniger fordernd wie vielleicht für euch
zu hause wo die bewegung nicht so oft
gemacht wird okay da stern wie schaut er
aus ja zeigt uns das einmal so wir gehen
in die also nach außen zu sammeln und
diese diagonale also die andere gerät
sprung seitlich gerät sprung diagonal
gerät sprung seitlich gerät sprung
andere diagonale das ist das besser
gesagt
genau das ist das was ihr das macht das
anleihen nicht mehr sein du bist da
trainiere dann macht euch bereit locker
zeitnahme kurz aus weil in zehn sekunden
starten mit dem gerät sprüngen in den
drei richtungen
43 21 grad
und da ihr seht und hört sich vielleicht
da die sie ganz schnellen bodenkontakt
des tap tap tap tap tap tap das ist es
was das badminton spielen glaube
ausmacht diese kurzen reaktiven
bewegungen das heißt nicht langsam und
schwerfällig sein sondern ganz kurze
bodenkontakt und explosiver arbeiten von
der leyen arbeit her noch fünf sekunden
[Applaus]
32 und übung haben erledigt jetzt kommt
wir eine altbekannte der knie hebel auf
nicki darf gebieten das ganz gut zumal
vorzuzeigen
das heißt oberkörper bleibt aufrecht
eine luftbewegung normal und jetzt knie
hochheben dankeschön kurz aus lockerer
und das mit möglichst kurzen boden
kontakten bin ich da richtig das ist das
a und o um was es geht und die letzten
zehn sekunden beißen und die letzten
zehn sekunden nochmals auszeichnen und
richtig eine passen genau so machen wir
das und in drei sekunden starten wieder
los zu 1 und knie belaufen wie bist du
zum batman spiel kommen
ganz zufällig weiterlaufen wir haben im
garten gespielt ich glaube sowie das
ganz viele machen und mir zusagt dass
mir einfach meine eltern sprechen haben
müssen dass man die halle gehen dann war
ein verein ausgeschrieben und am tag
darauf habe ich mich wieder auf die
letzten fünf sehr cool sehr gut das
heißt schon viele viele jahre dem sport
treu verbunden ganz kleider aus 30
sekunden sind vorbei wir haben die
vierte übung sommer bereits fünfte übung
und dann haben wir seit dem ersten satz
das heißt depping im stern wir beginnen
linkes bein stand beim wie schaut es aus
genau zu schauen das ist qualitativ
nämlich gar nicht so ohne arme langsam
bitte für uns zum mittag also zweimal
hier zweimal vorne zwei mal drauf ok
wieder seitlich dann hinten und wieder
raus ag und das ganze 30 sekunden in der
reihe und wichtig für euch zu hause
jetzt da ihr springt am besten wenn ihr
hinein kommen wollte mal panik
und erst auf den bei einigen sprung dann
immer weiter springen dann die bewegung
mit den bayern dazu machen jetzt bereit
da geht's los 30 sekunden arbeitszeit
[Applaus]
man ganz ehrlich war es nicht ganz so
funktioniert mit vorne links rechts
seite auch für hobby springen weit wenig
mit bein bewegen des mit dass kaufmann
ein
dann sah man hat keines badminton profis
im training drinnen aber bewegen man
trotzdem also keine sorge zehn sekunden
ja das sehr gut für das stand für die
wahl bin sicher die die mitmachen die
spüren dass das die wahrheit drin ist
wird ganz genau 30 sekunden durch
gleich ausprobieren wie funktioniert die
zweite seite weil es muss man natürlich
umdenken standbein halblinks jetzt
machen was rechts und die bewegung dazu
zeitlich vor allem hoch seitlich hinten
und dann geht's los 30 sekunden arbeit
immer wieder durch und er schaut super
super easy und super einfach als war
schätzt wie oft dass die übungen markt
ich glaube ja nicht tausend mal gesagt
wirklich nicht ja also das denkmal das
schaut sehr flüssig aus und wie gesagt
eine übung die sowohl koordinative diese
vorhand ist wie auch entsprechend die
abdrücke das standbein arbeitet die wade
arbeitet und die zweite spiel aus 30
sekunden sie immer durch sexy hammer was
kommt jetzt
du musst mir helfen ich muss erst aus
wenn hier machen wir machen wieder eine
übung eine klassische altbekannte an
fersen
die kämpfer aus einer lauf abc also
einer lauftechnik heraus das heißt
einfach nur nicht das knie von erheben
sondern versuchen hinten mit der ferse
richtung gesäß zu schlagen 50 kurve ich
glaube dass wir gar nicht vorzeigen das
wissen wir wie es ausschaut 321 zeit
läuft
ob ihr die hände jetzt in einer
laufbewegung mitnehmen sowie die hände
hinten aufs gesäß gibt es das hier spürt
man das waren die verse anschlägt durch
euch überlassen beide varianten sind
okay und gut und daher versuchen
möglichst kurze zeit nur am boden zu
sein
sehen sie konnten 53 zu wort aus ja ich
merke links und rechts von mir der
kreislauf kommt in schwung die atmung
fangen dann etwas intensiver zu werden
aber das ist gut weil genau das ist es
was mit trainieren wollen und wofür man
da sein für ausdauertraining ok
siegchance wie schauen wir es geschafft
dass ihr beidbeinig springt möglichst
gestreckte beine das heißt nicht immer
intensiv hineinlaufen landen sondern wir
springen wieder aus dem sprunggelenk
hauptsächlich mit der wadenmuskulatur
eine dynamische schnelle bewegung kurze
boden kontakte denner dolce los 30
sekunden
wir arbeiten wieder mal kein trick
versuchen euch exklusiv abzudrücken
schnell abzudrücken so dass ihr
entsprechend kurz war am boden satz aber
dann möglichst lang fliegt noch zehn
sekunden noch 54 32 und wieder ausloggen
mit spürbarer andere belastung wie beim
laufen weiter läuft das sehr viel aber
das ist schon mal ganz was anderes
also das ist schon eine sehr fordernde
in dem bereich für die wade
roter teppich seitlich ja sag mal zwei
meter 2002 so schnelles laufen gerne
aufsteigen in die grätsche quasi und
wieder zusammenkommen
ok kreativ jetzt nicht ganz so
herausfordernd zumindest schauen was uns
klar wie es funktioniert und 21 zeit
läuft es ist so wie wenn ihr ein leiter
training macht zu hause das heißt diese
koordinations leute am boden haben und
entsprechend drüber läuft das wäre eine
klassische übung die man da natürlich
machen kann jetzt aber den platz nicht
haben kann man das natürlich auch am
stand machen und möglichst kurze
bodenkontakt und möglichst schnell
arbeiten man sieht der ketscher dahinter
fünf sekunden rossis koordination
horstmann und 2 das aus ok ja es ist gar
nicht so einfach vor allem wenn man das
das erste mal macht dann ist das schon
richtig herausfordern aber jetzt haben
wieder übung für dich hock sprünge da
braucht sie jetzt nicht böse gemeint
nicht viel denken einfach nur arbeiten
kniehoch m springen springen springe 30
sekunden volle belastung und dem zehn
sekunden startet das heißt bereitet sich
vor macht euch bereit und dann geht es
los ich hoffe du fragst mich dann nicht
gleich sondern versuche ich mich
zurückzuholen aber jetzt kommt natürlich
das herz kreislauf system massiv in
schwung ja geht raus hohe intensive
sprünge trotzdem kurzer bodenkontakt
halbzeit nach 10 sekunden durchbeißen
die letzten zehn von den hawks sprüngen
5 4 3 2 1
kurze satzpause kurze serien pause keine
ausloggen beine ausschütteln ja cool
gemacht erster durchgang ist erledigt
die schweiz der anstrengend waren zum
schluss hin aber auf jeden fall also das
wird nie langweilig wenn man macht auch
immer besser wird immer schneller man
kann sich immer flüssiger machen bringt
so ein schluck wasser zeigt kurz aus
trotz dass das kreislaufsystem das herz
kreislauf system kurz einmal reguliert
und dann macht man auch im zweiten
durchgang und dann haben wir cool das
aufbauwerk hat bereits wieder erledigt
bis 6
beinarbeit ist nicht nur für den
badminton spieler ganz wichtige
geschichte sondern das kamera eins zu
eins in jeder kampfsport übung in jedem
bereich entsprechend umwandeln jeder
boxer braucht deine arbeit der kickboxer
braucht beinarbeit so wie es der
badmintonspieler braucht also diese
übungen der doors sechs cancer in jedes
kampfsport training beispielsweise auch
ganz gut mit einbauen
ok reguliert sich einmal messen eure
herzfrequenz das heißt es einmal als
titel zurück schaut schon auf die uhr
zehn sekunden pulsmesser mit herz
kreislauf system sollte sich wieder
herunter regulieren höher bei man
vielleicht ein bisschen höher bei man
ein bisschen niedriger
aber wenn es so im bereich von 120 110
120 wieder reinkommt dann ist es
definitiv bereit für den zweiten
durchgang
ich glaube wenn man das so anhöre auch
vom atmen ersatz bereit oder einige
blogger ja bereits an harry vorschlag
wir starten los mit der ersten übung
wieder nähmaschine
das heißt laufen am stand möglichst
schnell möglichst rasch kurze
bodenkontakt zeiten und geschlossen
[Applaus]
genau das sieht dann die muskeln da
geht's richtig ab kurze kontakte so
schnell wie möglich arbeiten zehn
sekunden nach 321 sei es aus kurz aus
lockern
kurze pause wer jetzt kommt wieder eine
muskuläre wesentlich belastet darüber
jetzt geht es nicht um die frequenz
sondern um die tiefe ausfallschritt
sprünge
das heißt da sein muskulär wieder voll
belastet das heißt kurz arme vielleicht
hinein position finden und staaten das
ganze in zehn sekunden 10 sekunden
geht's los ausfallschritt wechsel
sprünge 5 macht euch bereit 3 2 1 und
schloss aufrechte position oberkörper
gerade muskulär abgesichert und spannung
ist immer vorhanden kontrolliert etwa
beatmen beinachse akten das sagen die
wichtigen punkte die bei sowas immer
berücksichtigen müssen und immer
mitnehmen
nach zehn sekunden dann satz gleich
wieder durch fünf vier drei zwei eins
aus perfektes timing kurz mal versorgen
genau so da ihr habt jetzt die zweite
übung ausfallschritt sprünge erledigt
jetzt geht es eine in das stepping
wieder mit dem stern
das heißt wir fangen wieder an mit wenig
springen und dann das bein zeitlich
herstellen nach vorne nach hinten und
mit dem knie nach oben ok nicht ganz
denn es gab es vielleicht locker du
sagst du das noch mal ganz kurz an
durchgang war dass das meint das stimmt
du hast recht mein fehler gewesen du
warst richtig stern tapping das heißt
geld sprung und kitzscher los 30
sekunden
[Applaus]
kurze kontakte aufrechte position
schnell wieder weg vom boden besten
dinge achtet darauf zehn sekunden 5 noch
321 knebel auf das war sie das ist die
nächste übung eine relativ einfache
übung von der koordination her aber sehr
anstrengend für sie als kreislauf system
das heißt möglichst hoch das knie kann
der bewegung mitnehmen mit laufen
intensive belastung 15 sekunden
ausschnitten aus bewegen und dann geht's
wieder los
ja es ist angenehm wander erinnern also
wobei ich bin nicht immer wieder euch
die ihr da drin jetzt weil der junge
immer in den füßen und in den händen
selbst mitzumachen
aber ja die darf es dann im nachhinein
probieren weil mixa auf youtube kennt
natürlich das ganze aber immer wieder
auch abrufen dass die die workouts
mittlerweile seien schon sehr weit
werden wir große zahl an wörter 12 in
jedem was drinnen ist schaut sich
anderen jetzt mit waren auch immer okay
war bereit mich drauf los geht's
[Applaus]
schnelle bewegung nie hoch gerade
muskulär gespannt
[Applaus]
zehn sekunden hohe frequenz man kann
jeden motivieren es geht immer besser
[Applaus]
30 sekunden durch gearbeitet jetzt da
kommt der stern mit tapping seite vor
hoch wie auch immer nicht nur noch zwei
seitlich zweimal vorne zweimal oben
zweimal seitlich zweimal hinten 2
und wieder okay so einfach ist was kann
genauso ist es passt dann bereit machen
fünf sekunden start los
321 zeit läuft jetzt versuchen wir ganz
gemeine fragen zu stellen oder
rechenaufgaben geben und schauen ob die
bewegung schon soweit automatisiert ist
dass dabei kein fehler machst ich glaube
ich schaffen dann kommt das nächste mal
vielleicht überraschen was
[Applaus]
seit es aus lockern und gleich wieder
vorbereiten auf die zweite seite
das heißt gerne einspringen und
versuchen das zweite bein die andere
seite zu bewegen weil es wieder für den
kopf ganz andere bewegung ist und wie
gesagt zehn sekunden
wenn wir dann wieder in die
belastungsphase nach 3 2 1 los geht's
und nicht nachlassen nicht müde werden
kurze boden kontakte seien ganz wichtig
auch wenn es gegen ende vom training
hingeht muskulär mannes bereits spürt
der kurze schwarze bodenkontakt und den
gates und den wolle man bis zum schluss
aufrecht erhalten
[Applaus]
klar ist vorbei zeit ist durch und
wieder kurz aus locker und wir gehen
weiter
eine übung lauf abc anschließend genau
so ist es
das heißt da wieder da versuchen
entweder die hände hinten am gesäß
verschränken oder auch mitlaufen mit den
händen und entsprechend die phrase
richtung gesäß hoch bewegen und wieder
absetzen auch hier kurzer bodenkontakt
und möglichst viele kurze schnelle
bewegungen in den 30 sekunden einbauen
und die fünf sekunden starten mit der
übung an felsen also los noch 21 zeit
läuft das heißt man kann ab teilweise
übungen aus einem lauf techniktraining
aus einem lauftechnik programm natürlich
auch inter machen wenn es schwierig ist
also wirklich lauftechnik trainieren ist
natürlich autor wesentlich besser und
zielführender wie oft trainierst du
deine lauftechnik ganz schnell auch wenn
man das diesmal das ist so wie das
mobilisieren vor der einheit sei das aus
30 sekunden durch
also dass es wieder mobilisieren vor
allem krafttraining macht man bevor man
weglaufen übungen um entsprechend dort
technisch sie immer diese
weiterzuentwickeln siegchance wer sich
von euch nicht erinnern kann bei einige
sprünge knie möglichst gestreckt kurze
bodenkontakt und trotzdem möglichst hoch
springen aber das gut zusammenfasst
könnte es besser sein okay macht sich
bereit in fünf sekunden legen wir mit
steve jobs wieder los noch 21 zeit läuft
30 sekunden explosives herausdrücken aus
dem aus der wadenmuskulatur dass der
arbeiten die oberschenkel jetzt nur
stabilisierend die hauptarbeit kommt
doch aus der bahn
nach zehn und sein okay wir müssen ein
bisschen anzahl ja das haben wir aus
daten die man zwischendrin anscheinend
ein bisserl verplaudert wir gehen können
die nächste übung hinein
depping wieder was schnelleres jahr
wieder schneller an und damit zweimal
aus und los geht's auch hier 30 sekunden
belasten
schnelle bewegung aufrecht halten kurze
bodenkontakt
nach fünf sekunden und letzte übung die
intensivste übung war wenige also für
mich zumindest beim zuschauen die
intensivste übung für euch
wahrscheinlich auch vom trainieren her
das heißt armen tief durchschnaufen tief
durchatmen 30 sekunden hock sprünge
starter in fünf sekunden macht euch
bereit 321 vielleicht in der wohnung
wenn der nachbar unterhalb schon mit
besen quasi an die decke kluft versuchen
möglichst sanft zu landen
und wie gesagt in 20 10 bzw
zehn sekunden ist das werk hat ja eh
vorbei dann ist er wieder ruhiger die
letzten sprünge doch drei noch 2 1 und
das war es 30 minuten ausdauer
berghammer erledigt für euch jetzt zu
hause
cool down phase einleiten bewegen am
stand aus lockern ausschütten
das sind die dinge die es jetzt am
besten noch ein paar minuten nach macht
luca ich sage danke dass du da warst
gerne
danke für das tolle programm wir werden
das sicherlich auch im einen oder
anderen unserer workshops mit einbauen
gerade diese qualitative komponente ist
immer wieder ein sehr wichtiger punkt an
unserem training ja wir wünschen dir
alles gute für die olympia-quali häufig
einander zuhören quasi wenn es um die
medaillen dann geht vielleicht ist es
eine variante
du kannst dich etwas anfangen oder ich
kann das damit anfangen ich schätze mal
dass ich mich qualifiziert
genau also jetzt mein hauptfokus und
wenn ich das schafft euch weiter gut
sagt dann wünsche ich alles gute dafür
was möchte es den leuten damit geben um
sich fit zu halten
ja einfach dass man es regelmäßig macht
dass man es als routine hat dass man
sich irgendwo was hin bit oder so dass
man nicht vergisst
lieber bisserl weniger machen dafür
regelmäßig glaube ok danke schön für die
regelmäßigkeit ist sicherlich einer der
wichtigsten punkte überhaupt in bewegung
und beim sport wenn die regelmäßig daran
dann kann ja wirklich besser werden und
dann ist das eine gute variante indem er
sie vielleicht am kühlschrank irgendwo
liste hinblickt wo man abhaken kann das
training habe ich gemacht und das ist
noch ausständig
motivation oder auch erinnerung das wars
von uns heute wir sehen uns morgen am
freitag zum letzten berg hat intensives
werk military fitness noch einmal und
entsprechend wir freuen uns auf morgen
und hoffentlich wieder mit dabei
dankeschön